[音楽]
voodoo
皆さんはですねぴ女武将に行ったことはありません
私も行ったことはありませんでした
そして
どこにあるサイ知らなかったん
そしてその中で
人生を得やり直したくて困っているそんな人がいることも知りませんでした
私は病院でリハビリの仕事をしています
q 2能宗中になってそして
薬や tuesday
犬中は何とか取りております
でもで足が動かない
子供を満足に話せない
そういった一つ
それに
私はリハビリーという色を提供しています
リハビリの知識はたくさんありますそして腕も自分では自信があります
でも
患者さんが諦めてしまったら
心は治すことができない
学校では
心の治し方は教えてもらえません
そこで私は
スピーチクラブに入りました
スピーチまっこんなところでですね人前で話す
話はあると
パスコアユバール買ったら
あそこの言葉間違えちゃったちょっと思い出せなかった
そんな子冒険を
本当にもう嫌になってしまう
プロといいんですね仲間のみんなが拍手してくれる
そしてアソコが残ったよここを感動した
すごく嬉しかったよ面白かったよ
でもここをもう少しこういうふうに変えたらもっと良くなるんじゃないか
お互いにアドバイスをします
そうすると自信をつけてまたもう1回チャレンジしよう
そんな気持ちになるんです
この
心をよみがえられている
そうして勇気を与える
その力を私はこのスポーツクラブからもらってそうしてリハビリにかしています
患者さんの心を助けるリハビリです
早いそういったビッグクラブに入っていて
いつものように
グラブの会本を読んでいました
20年くらいの前の話ですね
そしてある鬼人
目が止まったんです
それはゲーム所の中で受給者がスピーチクラブをやっている
そしてスピーチをやってアドバイスをするスピーチをやったアドバイスを繰り返して
いるうちに考え方を変えて
見方を変えてそして
再犯率はほとんど
0パーセントになる
氷はすごい
日本でもやりたい
私はそう思いました
でもその頃まだ
日本には
日本語の g ほとんどなかったですし
そして
日本語のマニュアルも
ほとんどありませんでした
私は日本語のクラブをつくってそして
へこのマニュアルを日本語に訳してい
それから日本自分の役員になってクラブを増やしていきました
10年経った時です
私は資料をそろえてそれを刑務所に送り
そして仲間の会員と一緒に
そこの pa 部署に行きました
そして
説明をしましたん
するとまず聞かれたのはですね
他の刑務所で行っていますか
いやここは初めてなんです
前例がないことは日本とはできないですね
そして
刑務所のプログラムというのは全部法務省で決まってるんですよ
勝手にこのゲーム層だけね新しいのやることができません
旅行並び
そして
アメリカではボランティアやっている
でもね日本ではねボランティアができないんですよ
私はすごすごと帰るしかありませんでした
でも
私にはスポーツクラブがあります
スポーツクラブに入ってスピーチをしました
僕はぜひ日本でもこの刑務所のスピーチクラブやりたいんだ
そうしたらそこで聞いていた仲間の弁護士買う
メモさあこれ見てくださいよ
これ
政府が
10年で再犯率を20%下げる
大訳していましたよ
そのためにここ見てほらう
コミュニケーション能力を高め
民間
mpo ボランティアそういったもの市民を活用する
書いてあるじゃないですか
チャンスですよ
私
違いに国会議員元法務大臣がいるので
たロビン木ましょう
彼の地元の
国会議員の事務所まずために行きます
秘書さんに説明してそれからそのおっ会員から電話がかかってきました
公開議員会館に来てください
仲間と行くと
俺は素晴らしい
自分が法務大臣だった時に
伊礼部署から出てっても
すぐ戻ってきてしまう
何とかしたかったけれどもどうしていいか分からなかった
こんな素晴らしいブローラーがあるんだったらぜひやってくれ
もうその場でこうむしょん出ましてそれから法務省で打ち合わせ
企画官がスピーチクラブに
視察に来てそうして
ゲーム所で始めることになりました
私は
俺は仲間を集めなきゃいけない
そして日本支部の総会に行って
ぜひ
これをネイ
刑務所でやっていく委員会をつくりましょう
テーマもしないん
ところが
半分の会員は俺は素晴らしい
と認めてくれたんですが
薬は反対です
妻日
このスペース喰らう
1いう起用がじゃない研修で使っているプログラムです
だから
受刑者とは彼から依頼は持ちたくないん
私は渋々そう提案を取り下げました
その時
一緒にクラブを増やしてきた
同じ役員が
挨拶もしてくれない
薄くつらなんです
ちょっと辛いんでここからちょっとラップ入れてもいいですかね
法務省の
home 大字上から入ると
上から入ると
現場の反発半端ない
そこは何です
本当にですね
ハンパないですつまり
何かあったら誰が責任取るの
えっ
なんか問題があったら君たちが何か消費してくれるの
受刑者にも会わせてもらえない
つまり新しいこと余計なことは
やっぱりやりたくないんですって誰でも私もそうですけれども
でも
そういったところで
最初
なんにもいた仲間が
一人減り二人ヘビー
毎月委員会あったんですけれども
最後は私と日
でその弁護士さん来てい
あ良さ
また今日も一人だったの
う相談
で彼は言いました
アメリカに行こう
アメリカで本当の刑務所スピーチクラブを見てこようよ
2して私はアメリカのボランティアに連絡をとって
てが視界が坊主頭に飛びました
そこで
アメリカのメンバーが迎えてくれて k 部署を8つ案内してくれました
その刑務所の中で私はスピーチをしました
アンチャ2 samurai
日本では
失敗したら花木
電をここは自由の国アメリカ
アイオニア海た草や木になぁ
失敗したってやり直してそして
アメリカンドリームを考えるだろう
税理君たちのやっていることを教えてくれ
受刑者は全貌を教えてくれました
そしてボランティアも自分たちの失敗も前防止 l 4教えてくれました
その中で
一つ
ものすごい出来事がありました
特許はその話もしましょう
マーキス舞うセキュリティ10型機の顕著です
もう一を何か殺してきた
あれば犯罪
それから
殺人
そうした人たちが天平から集まってくるゲームつです
木彫の中から
この中から全部調べられる金属探知機とってそして動画こんな暑いんですよ
それを
1万円ドアを開けて
で入ってで
また内路が始まって次のドアを開けて
幸福前通りましたかねぇ
その一番奥にその教室がありました
でその教室に
私たちボランティア入ると
護衛の刑務官
彼は
では
今からよろしく
携帯の
ko 機を
私て
そして
帰っていってしまいました
そういった
図形さと私たちボランティアだけ
水ちょっと緊張したんで後ろの受刑者に話しかけました
君どっから来たんだい
フェルトいこ
あ納付ヤルゴイこの友達がいるよ
そんな話をしてた時に当然です
んん
だからた登山にどれがなった相手国人の警官がマシン具を持って入ってきました
並べる
誰も動くらー
今敬語が押されました
自分のベルを見てください
私は自分のベルを見ました
すいません
私のベルが押されていましです
はいよかったですねあの子方です
大丈夫でしたね
軍艦たちは帰ってきました
私は本当に穴があったら入りない
後でその弁護士から
現地のボランティアは本当にね問題を起こさないように
本当にも注意した流行ってるのに埋めもさんなんてことしてくれたんだ
お子さんが奢られましたが
本当に落ち込んでいましてで
レモ
q 経営者は
慰めてくれるんです
わざとやったわけじゃないだろう
失敗音って誰だって失敗することはあるな
大丈夫だよ
人を殺すという
大きな失敗をした人ですから妙に説得力ありましたけど
そして
論題ここが一番安全な所なんてわかっただろう
何かあると
売りガードがを6人パッと入ってきてくれる助けてくれ
世界でここ良い安全な場所はないよ
やそう言われればそうだな
でもなんか私は嬉しくて涙が出そうでした
彼らは私たちのためにスピーチをしてくれました
自分は人を殺してきた
こうしたときは
これは自分の正義だ殺して相手が悪いんだ
そういうふうに思っていたん
でもスピーチと論評を繰り返していくうちず
考えが変わってきた
あの頃したやつ
彼にも家族がいたった
小さい子供がいたんだ
その家族の未来も自分は埋まってしまった
人は
このスピーチグラムのおかげで
自分のを変えることができた
ぜひ日本でもこのスポーツクラブをやってくれ
頑張ってくれ
そう言われました
私は帰りの飛行機の中で
初見名でボードがきました
それを弁護士が
スタート報告書にまとめてくれて法務省に出しました
そうするとその8つの刑務所を回ってきた
軌道は伝わりますよね
法務省は
東大出のいいリード刑務官を送ってきてそして
現場の調整それからブログラムも一つにあったような形に書き換えて
そして最後には
刑務所長と協定書を結んで日本で初めて
救助のボランティア字筆倶楽部を始めることになったん
そして
今やへ
みんなこう口コミとか sns で
立っ
最初怖かったけどすごいよ
なんか楽しかった母
すごい
教えに行ったんだけど学ぶことのほうが多かった
いろんなことは伝わると仲間がどんどん集まってきます
今はもう70名以上を超える mbo になりました
そうです
社会が変わっていくんです
社会が変わる
刑務所から出てきて
逢妻と悪いことをするだろう
んな
あいつ
信用できないな
と言われるようにも
ゆとり
頑張ってティンズやり直そうと思ってんだから助けてあげようよ
そういう人が増えた方がいいと思いませんか
今日皆さんは
知ってしまいました
警備その中で何があるか
そして事務所の外出るできることもたくさんあります
さあスってしまった皆さん
皆さんは
あなたは
何をしますか
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]